hi I'm Dina - curry with aj+ you might
remember Nelson Mandela as this man the
peacemaker who led South Africa post
apartheid but to really understand him
you also have to know this man
the young defiant rebel who was so
committed to liberating his country he
was willing to die for the cause this is
a look at Mandela the rebel his birth
name was holy hala which means
troublemaker and he lived up to that
name from a young age Mandela got kicked
out of college for taking part in a
student strike and then ran away from
home to avoid an arranged marriage
it was 1941 in Johannesburg and black
South Africans didn't have many rights
so Mandela became active in the African
National Congress or ANC a black
liberation movement when apartheid
became official law mandela and other
activists fought back by organizing acts
of civil disobedience like the defiance
campaign
that's when thousands of non-whites
provoked arrests by deliberately
breaking apartheid laws and while
Mandela would later go on to win a Nobel
Peace Prize he was no pacifist in fact
as the freedom struggle evolved he even
advocated armed resistance after the
Sharpeville massacre in 1961 police
killed 69 protesters Mandela co-founded
the ANC's militant wing it was called
want OSC's way or MK which means spear
of the nation around that time Mandela
had this to say about non-violence there
are many people feel that it is useless
and futile for us to continue talking
peace and non-violence again the
government would reply is only savage
attacks on an unarmed and defenseless
people faced with such a regime and as a
last resort ANC leaders considered
sabotage guerrilla warfare terrorism and
open revolution they decided to start
with sabotage because they wanted to
avoid the loss of life keep in mind the
goal was still political reconciliation
and a non-racial society as originally
outlined in a landmark document called
the Freedom Charter on December 16 1961
MK set off homemade bombs at power
stations and government
offices around the country and the weeks
to come there were more bombing
campaigns no civilians were killed
during these incidents Mandela embraced
his role as a guerilla leader and even
trained with the Algerian National
Liberation Front outside the country but
in August 1962 he was arrested back in
South Africa and charged with sabotage
even though he faced the death penalty
Mandela remained defiant he gave a three
hour long speech at his trial ending
with a call for a democratic and free
society it is an idea of which I hope to
live and to see yellow
but my lord if it needs be
it is an again for which I am prepared
to die Mandela went on to jail for 27
years
but his ideal was eventually realized
sometimes it takes rebels to change the
world thanks for watching guys make sure
to like and comment and spread the
knowledge